one of the more difficult things that we
have to do as Leaders is let go in 2006
I had to take extreme ownership over a
friendly fire incident there was only
one person to blame and that person was
me I spent my adult life in the military
20 years Special Operations I've learned
that leadership is the most important
thing on the battlefield it's the most
important thing in business and really
it's the most important thing in life
what do you think makes a good leader
cultivating the best out of people yes
what else no matter what your job is
these skills will help you in every
aspect of your life
I'm Jocko willink and this
is Master Class
[Music]